well tonight authorities have named all
eight victims killed after fans swarmed
the stage at a travis scott concert in
houston which happened friday night and
they range in age from 14 years old to
27 and for more than half an hour after
authorities declared a mass casualty
event travis scott did continue to play
on so we've now learned he will not be
playing here at day in vegas which is
scheduled to happen next weekend joe
moller joining us now from the festival
grounds with more
joe lot of people on social media were
wondering if day in vegas would be
canceling travis scott's performance
well it turns out he reportedly is
deciding to not perform this saturday
setup is already underway for the
festival which starts on friday and goes
through sunday one person we talked to
who was attending says she's going to
think twice before heading into a large
crowd
my happy place is like in a crowd at a
concert and so hearing something like
that it was just really heartbreaking
nina roll will be making her way today
in vegas from california it would be a
really bad look if like a week later
after something like that happened he's
going to go and perform at another
festival it just doesn't make sense she
says that scott did not cancel she would
have skipped his performance i used to
always join kind of in that middle crowd
trying to get close to the stage i i'm
definitely i'm thinking about being more
strategic staying towards the back
rowell says she is wondering who if
anyone will replace scott at day in
vegas he was set to take the stage
saturday this is the second time he has
canceled last year was due to an injury
it's very sad to see that you know
these waves of people
have caused some people to lose their
lives justin landers photographs
concerts and events he says too many
people in one venue can become victims
in something called crowd crush what it
is is that so many people have actually
packed into that point that when that
crowd moves you can't go anywhere he's
happy scott canceled his performance he
says the deaths could have been
prevented i think it's important that
every event every festival takes the
first the first step to be
how do we control the amount of people
in each area
now back out here live we did reach out
to golden voice the company organizing
day in vegas about their safety
protocols that they have in place for
things sort of like what happened in
houston
but we have not heard back from them
just yet the festival here starts on
friday and again goes through sunday
reporting live joe mullen live local now